[Applause]
so this is a real thing um I didn't mean
to stab you with my fake mail um uh I
literally had one request this season
I'm not kidding and it was I really
wanted there were two requests Alanis
Moret and Teddy swims these are my these
are my it was my two I was like I I
literally I was just I just wanted to
meet you because I'm such a fan and I
feel like I know you because I've
stalked to you so much online um and I
just think you're incredible
um so thank you for being here on our
holiday show PR I'm me obviously giant
fan as well whatever you don't have to
be but wait do you get into Christmas we
we're celebrating the holidays do you
were you like the kid to like unwrap
your presents and wrap them back up yeah
um so actually there was a time and my
mom's probably going to hear this now
and be very upset but um I think parents
know yeah well this this we got away
with it so remember when that Rock Band
game came out like wherever ago and we
we found out like it was in this big
giant box and it was already wrapped but
he had found a way to we could just peel
the tape back and we pulled all the
instruments out of it and closed it back
up and so it was just a big empty box in
there completely tape shut and we played
that game for like 3 weeks and she had
no idea that ever happened and like the
day before we just slid it back in kind
of and she when she pulled it out oh my
God you got Rock Band for us this is
crazy knowing that we had already beaten
that game two weeks ago first of all you
bring it out and they're like they're
prodigies they're playing it so well we
had already had downloaded I mean she
probably saw a credit
card downlo extra songs like she I know
she had to have known right I love that
you just take the haird dryer to release
that tape kids just so you know take the
hairy release it slide it on off yeah I
actually never did it I'm pretty sure my
older siblings did but I never I never
did it I don't know why I felt bad about
it I don't know I have a lot of
fear like I got to know I gotta know
everything that someone's getting me
there's no surprises I am not curious at
all about things sometimes yeah I'm good
with not knowing but how did you choose
the title of your album you know I've
tried everything but therapy part one
but I just here well one I'm going to
ask you have you ever really tried
therapy but two I kind of love that it's
the title of the album because I feel
like it is therapeutic what we do
naturally yeah absolutely I mean it's
therapeutic for me in a lot of ways but
I think too it was it was something
where I wanted to start the conversation
within myself because I think like this
generation probably is like the first
people that are like normalizing just
talking about mental health at all and
getting the ation going at all because
uh I feel like somewhere in like
generational like some some mindset
where it was like I'm not going to
therapy I'm not crazy or I'm like I
don't need that or I know what's wrong
with me don't you know and I feel like
we just or in my world it was like talk
to your preacher yeah it was like and
it's like well that can be helpful
definitely but like you know also people
that are trained in another version
another way to give you tools yeah yeah
and so I think I think just having that
and if I if I start that conversation
hopefully maybe it'll Inspire somebody
else to have that conversation and go
get the help and do the work for
themselves absolutely um I'm I'm
currently in a process I've talked to a
couple people but also have been like in
this place too where um it's it's doing
what we do too and on this rocket ship
that I'm kind of currently on I need I
also want somebody to kind of help me
navigate that and to understand also
what I'm at and not like you know it's
just got to you got to find the right
person for you yeah because it does
happen fast no matter how many years cuz
it's not fast you've been doing it for
minute but when it does happen I do feel
like it doesn't in anyone's career you
can hitting it for like years and years
and years but when it takes off it takes
off and it's so it's it's alarming it's
like just yeah here like oh no yeah hold
on go here we go you know and then
everybody says oh you g to say yes to
everything you never know when it's
going to stop you never and then you're
worn out so by the way take advice this
advice it'll always be there because
your gift is there so people will always
want to you know what I'm saying you
have a god-given talent that is so rare
like people always trying to get you to
say yes to everything say yes to things
you want to say yes to but like it is
important to also say no um because you
wear yourself out yeah yeah we're
working on boundaries yeah we sure are
because I really am not I'm not good at
boundaries I am not good at them I don't
think most I'm so bad I'm like sure yeah
sounds like a great plan and then
meanwhile I'm not tired at all I'm a
robot keep the to kilo and yeah and that
ends well that'll lead you to another
album part two um so explain explain
your song Lose Control I love this song
so much it's so good so um I was I was
in a relationship at a time and um me
and this person were we're kind of I
think I think it got to a point where
the substance of our relationship was
kind of the substances we were abusing
at the time you know and and our high
highs were just so high and just so
beautiful and the lows were just very
awful and became quite toxic and we came
very codependent on each other and and
the things we were doing together and
the lifestyle we were living together
and and no matter how much you love
someone and you guys love each other
sometimes you're just bad for each other
you know and just kind of we're dragging
each other into just to hits of Hell
basically you know and and we had to we
had to separate in order to like I think
for the best of both of us for both to
heal and to uh understand what was going
on because I felt like we were just kind
of punish punishing each other for what
you do in love just punish each other
for trauma that's not right you just
like because you almost have to fix
separately and then come yeah you can't
can't be in charge of somebody's
happiness you know it's hard enough
being in charge of your own I'm sure is
yeah debut album is out now it's called
I've tried everything but therapy part
one it's cuz you're too young you'll get
there uh speaking of therapy it is the
holidays and Teddy and I are both
obsessed with the holidays who isn't
except for scrudge um in the Grinch but
what specifically do we love about this
time of year well it's time to break it
down with a special edition of
obsessions this
is
holiday
obsessions that's a new one that's a new
one I love this tun all right we love
some tunes here um that's right it's
time to embrace our holiday obsessions
I'm going to hit this magical button and
the topic will be selected by our super
festive supercomputer because we are
rich and have a huge budget then the
person obsessed with the topic will own
up and sell everybody on it I have no
idea what's going to happen anyway let's
go I'm first here we go I
didn't what do we got
here shange your red houses and bul my
manager's making fun of me I haven't
seen these okay so I this just happened
the other day my kids we do gingerbread
houses we build them every year but they
come out with new ones that are very
exciting they have a tree house one this
year they have a beach house they have
all these little so I buy a lot of them
Teddy I I'm not even going to K sticky I
just can't stand it stick oh my God I
love it sticky I love it well I do it to
where we can make a mess and then you
just like pile it up in the bag and then
you tie it up and throw it away I do it
in a smart way there's no Glitter
involved um but no I love it I get I get
tons of gingerbread houses and we make
them all like nightly during the
holidays it's a lot I like crafts yeah
crafts but I don't let them eat it they
get really angry about that but the
candies never use a good on those things
is they're children they will eat
anything yeah yeah they will they I love
them mean that sometimes only on
weekends they're garbage disposals I'm
telling you like my son will literally
pick it up off the ground I'm like all
right free probiotic any I'm obsessed
with them I literally brought over
20 anyway but we do them all they all
it's all for a good cause for cheer um
anyway um your turn I'm
crazy right let's see what happens now
rent yes like paying rent or or no like
uh like rent the musical oh rent yeah so
um my senior year I got to be in that
show and I played Roger and my my best
friend Jesse who's in my band he played
he played Mark and we were best buzs in
that and um I could play every character
from top to bottom and that I know every
word to that whole show and me and my
moms watch it every time I go home for
Christmas and we just watch the Broadway
version the DVD they pull out the dust
off the old DVD player and everything
baby it's it's my favorite show in the
world I just I'm so obsessed with it
this is how I know I'm so much older
than you I dust off a a VHS
brother just pop that puppy in for BHS I
was around for VHS I love that though
that's so special I love that musical
too christm like you know my my
Christmas tradition with Mom yeah okay
everybody those were
our
Obsession I like it I like it the song
the jingles I'm tell the jingles they go
hard on the jingles it's very funny
usually the other obsessions is very
sexy we kept it family for Christmas um
Teddy Teddy and I are performing his
song Lose Control later in the show so
stick around for my favorite moment this
year his debut album is called I've
tried everything but therapy part one
you've got to get it it's so great y'all
we'll be right back with some holiday
gift
[Applause]
[Music]
ideas thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home